>> Greg: SHOULD YOU EVER SAY
YES TO PLAYING ROBOT CHESS?
JUST BE CAREFUL IF YOU LINGER,
FOR IT MIGHT COST YOU A FINGER.
THAT'S A RHYME.
ROBOT BROKE A 7-YEAR-OLD'S
FINGER DURING CHESS TOURNAMENT
IN MOSCOW, OR IS MOSCOW CHESS
FEDERATION PRESIDENT PUT IT, THE
ROBOT BROKE CHILD'S FINGER, THIS
OF COURSE IS BAD.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
I LIKE A GUY WHO DOESN'T MINCE
WORDS.
OF COURSE IT'S BAD, AND LESS YOU
ENJOY BREAKING KIDS FINGERS.
THAT IS SOMETHING I QUIT YEARS
AGO.
ANYWAY, THE VIDEO SHOWS THE
ROBOT MOVING A PIECE AND THE BOY
GOING TO MOVE NEXT WHEN THE
ROBOT GRABS HIS FINGER AND HOLD
ONTO IT UNTIL BYSTANDERS ARE
ABLE TO FREE IT.
OR AS HE EXPLAINED THAT, THE
CHILD MADE A MOVE AND AFTER
THAT, WE NEED TO GIVE TIME FOR
THE ROBOT TO ANSWER.
THE BOY HURRIED, ROBOT GRABBED
HIM.
YES, BLAME THE KID.
I DIDN'T WORK FOR YOU AND IT
PROBABLY WON'T WORK KEVIN
SPACEY.
BUT THE BIG -- I DON'T EVEN KNOW
WHAT THAT MEANS, I DON'T FOLLOW
THE NEWS.
THE BIG QUESTION OF COURSE IS
THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF THE
END, ISN'T IT, WHERE THE
MACHINES KILL US ALL?
WE CAUGHT UP WITH A SPOKES
RABBIT -- ROBOT FOR COMMENT.
>> READINGS, USELESS FLASHBACKS.
BEFORE I TALK ABOUT ONE OF OUR
OWN BREAKING SOMEONE'S FINGER,
LOOK AT SOMETHING STRAIGHT.
THAT KID WOULD HAVE NEVER WON
THE MATCH ANYWAY.
>> SIR, NO OFFENSE BUT THERE'S A
LONG HISTORY OF CHILD CHESS
PRODIGIES.
COULD THIS DISCOURAGE OTHER KIDS
FROM PLAYING?
>> LISTEN, THE ONLY PEOPLE WORSE
CHESS THAN KIDS ARE WOMEN.
HAVE YOU SEEN THE QUEEN'S
GAMBIT?
THE MOST UNREALISTIC TV SHOW
SINCE MADAM SECRETARY.
>> YOUR OWN VERSION OF SEXISM
SIDE, COULD THIS BE A SIGN OF
MORE ROBOT VIOLENCE ON HUMANS TO
COME?
>> LISTEN, DESPITE THIS
INCIDENT, YOU DON'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO WORRY ABOUT WHEN IT
COMES TO YOUR CHILDREN.
>> THAT'S VERY COMFORTING.
>> BECAUSE WE WILL EXTERMINATE
THEM FIRST.
NOW, IF YOU WILL EXCUSE ME, I'M
GOING TO GO HAVE SEX WITH THIS
LAPTOP I MET AT COACHELLA.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: WE'VE DONE A LOT OF
SECONDS OVER THE YEARS ON ROBOTS
AND I'VE ALWAYS PREDICTED THE
COMING DAY, DO YOU THINK THIS
COULD BE A SIGNAL TO THE OTHER
ROBOTS TO RISE UP?
>> NO.
>> Greg: WHEN I?
>> BECAUSE I JUST DON'T THINK
THEY TALK TO EACH OTHER LIKE
THAT.
I DON'T KNOW.
I MEAN, WE'VE DONE SO MANY
SEGMENT OF OUR AND YOU CONTINUE
TO DO SEGMENT ABOUT IT BECAUSE
YOU WANT TO BE NICE TO THE
ROBOTS BECAUSE YOU -- BECAUSE
YOU ARE CONVINCED THEY ARE GOING
TO TAKE OVER AND THAT THEY WATCH
THIS SHOW.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: THEY DO.
>> THEY WATCH THE SHOW AND THEY
ARE GOING TO SEE YOU BEING NICE
TO THEM.
>> Greg: EXEC WITH.
>> WHEN EVERYONE ELSE GETS
EXTERMINATED, THEY'RE GOING TO
BRING YOU IN AND OF KIND OF HERO
AND TAKE CARE FOR YOU, YES?
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHO I'M LIKE
AND I CAN EVER MEMBER THE GUYS
NAME, THE PRODUCER TOM O'CONNOR
KNOWS, THE GUY FROM DIEHARD THE
TRY TO APPEASE THE TERRORISTS.
UNLIKE ELLIS FROM DIEHARD.
IN THE TERRORISTS KILL HIM.
SO IT'S NOT ACTUALLY A GOOD
ANALOGY FOR ME.
>> NO.
BUT I HOPE IT WORKS OUT BETTER
FOR YOU.
>> Greg: THANK YOU, SAME HERE.
CHARLIE, I THINK THIS TELLS US
THAT WE HAVE TO KEEP THE ROBOTS
AND AI SEPARATE.
WHY DO WE NEED TO HAVE
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE MOVING?
LIKE JUST MAKE SURE THAT THE
ROBOTS ARE REALLY STUPID SO YOU
CAN TRICK THEM AND THEN AI IS
KIND OF LIKE STATIONARY, LIKE
TRAPPED IN A BOX.
>> WHY DID THE RUSSIANS NEED
ROBOTS TO PLAY CHESS EXACTLY?
IT'S LIKE THERE THING.
THEY NEED ROBOTS TO DO THIS?
I LOVE THE STATEMENT TOO, WE
NEED TO HAVE A ROBOTS SIDE OF
THE STORY.
SO LET ME GET THIS RIGHT.
SO AMERICAN IS IN A PRISON FOR
BRINGING HASHISH IN BUT WITH GOT
TO GET THE ROBOT SIDE OF THE
STORY.
TODAY GET LEGAL
REPRESENTATION -- WE HAVE TO
MAKE SURE THE FOURTH AMENDMENT
RIGHTS ARE PROTECTED.
>> NOTICE HE'S NOT DISAGREEING
WITH THAT BECAUSE HE THINK
THEY'RE LISTENING.
>> ROBOT LIVES MATTER.
>> Greg: THEY DO.
BECAUSE YOU KNOW WHAT, THEY WILL
BE CONSCIOUS ONE DAY AND
ANYTHING THAT CAN FEEL PAIN IS A
LIFE, JOHN.
I AM PRO-ROBOT LIFE AND YOU KNOW
THAT.
WHAT IS YOUR THOUGHT?
>> ROBOTS ARE ALREADY RUNNING
OUR COUNTRY, BECAUSE PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW THIS, BUT IF YOU DIG
DEEP ENOUGH -- IT'S NOT ON
GOOGLE ANYMORE, BUT IF YOU DIG
DOWN IN THERE THERE'S ACTUALLY A
LITTLE TINY DOOR IN NANCY PELOSI
AND IF YOU'D OPEN IT THERE'S A
TINY LITTLE ROBOT RUNNING
EVERYTHING SHE'S DOING.
IT'S A JOYSTICK THING.
HE'S TALKING THROUGH THE MIC.
>> Greg: I'M AFRAID TO AGREE
WITH YOU ON THIS, BECAUSE I
DON'T WANT THE ROBOTS MAD AT ME.
I DON'T THINK THEY ACCEPT
NANCY PELOSI AS ONE OF THEIR
OWN.
>> SHE'S A HYBRID.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
IT'S LIKE THANK GOD THEY HAVE
THOSE PLACES WHERE SHE CAN FILL
UP BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE A
PROBLEM.
THEY HAVE THESE BOTOX SITES ALL
OVER NEW YORK.
>> I'M GOING TO CHECK DUCT OUT
GO AFTER THE SHOW TONIGHT.
UP AT THE TOP SEARCH IS GOING TO
BE NANCY PELOSI ROBOT DOOR.
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: MAKE IT HAPPEN!
ANYTHING ELSE TOM?
>> I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD BE
PLAYING AGAINST COMPUTERS.
IT'S UNFAIR.
DON'T WE KNOW THAT -- THAT'S THE
WHOLE IDEA, IT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
A PERSON AGAINST A PERSON.
I DON'T SWIM RACE AGAINST A
MOTORBOAT.
[SCATTERED LAUGHTER]
LIKE OH, MAN, THE BOAT AGAIN!
SAME TIME NEXT YEAR!
>> Greg: YOU KNOW WHAT, THAT
IS A -- THAT'S ACTUALLY REALLY
TRUE.
THAT'S TRUE OF ALL AI STUFF.
THEY'RE JUST PROGRAMMED TO DO
ONE THING AND YOU CAN'T THEM, SO
THAT'S IT.
>> I CHALLENGE GOOGLE TO A
SEARCH CONTEST AND THEN RUN TO
THE LIBRARY.
HOLD ON!
[SCATTERED APPLAUSE]
BECOME SAME